1 immigration law that would concern
everyone except the Algerians.
We don't care about ourselves at all,
yet it is true
and that's why Republicans
have tabled 1 motion for a resolution
calling for an end to the Franco-Algerian agreement
of dix-neuf-cent-soixante-huit.
This agreement provides for derogations
favorable to Algerian nationals.
It has been revised 3 times
but without much change each time
and once again today,
with 1 vote against by the National Assembly,
the text will not move.
But why tackle this agreement now?
Simply put
because several measures of the bill
immigration currently under discussion in parliament
will not apply to Algerians.
For example,
Article 1
which requires 1 minimum level in French
to obtain 1
residence card
will not affect them.
The same goes for article 13
which conditions the stay in France to the strict respect
of the principles of the Republic.
Fuzzy notion
but it is assumed that knife attacks
to the cry of Allah akbar
are not part of it.
In short,
basically,
we will stutter on 1 law
which will not concern the 1st foreign community
of the country.
So a lot of noise for nothing
and especially 1 return to square one.